[Applaudissements]
bobigny alors vous allez vous demander
comment ça va se passer en france c'est
par cette déclaration donc annoncé un
grand changement sont mises en échec il
ya jaune d'oeuf de fonte et qu'on se
fait donc que ce comité miss france qui
a réagi ce matin et qu'elle dit qu'elle
aimerait qu'il se passe la même chose en
france est l'arrêt chez morandini live
est contacté par le huffington post
sylvie tellier a réagi le concours de
miss france rassemble de nombreux
téléspectateurs
c'est un programme qui fédère et plaît
beaucoup aux français ils sont attachés
à ces éléments aux robes de princesse
notamment si la question de savoir si le
comité miss france allait faire la même
chose elle a répondu on peut défiler en
maillot de bain être féministe on n'a
jamais obliger une femme à faire ce
qu'elles devraient pas faire bondir le
maillot avant ou la robe qu'elles
veulent porter mais sachez que voilà il
ya des mouvements qui milite pour que
les fumées et ces jeunes filles un vieux
ne soit vous vous aimez sont michel non
moi ce que j'aime c'est pas c'est pas le
fait que cette connerie son nom
d'annoncer que c'est plus un concours de
beauté c'est quoi ce moment là si c'est
pour un concours de culture jean larissa
voilà c'est ça il ya d'autres d'autres
lieux pour ça donc ça doit rester un
concours de beauté ça l'est encore qu'on
a ça n'a aucun sens
moi je suis d'accord que ça soit plus
une obligation d'être en bikini cercle
moi je voudrais qu'elle s'habille comme
elle veut et que sa part quelque chose
de le formater une tenue folklorique
mais qu'elles soient plus naturellement
revanche cela pas se limiter à une
connerie de jeunesse alors la porte
parole de m
raphaël reynes il le sait expliqué ce
matin sur rtl elle était assez sévère et
ses arguments on peut les comprendre à
raphaël joly écoutez c'est quand même
assez paradoxal pour un concours de
beauté de commencer à avancer sur ces
sujets là sont finalement se
réinterroger sur sa place dans la mise
en compétition des femmes le jugement
sur des critères assez artificiel elle
ne repose sur rien d'intéressant
ce qui est pointé c'est que maintenant
le concours va faire place aux femmes
pour leur intelligence leur capacité
d'engagement pourquoi organiser un
concours alors ça s'appelle juste la vie
de tous les jours du coup vous dites
quoi il faut supprimer aussi notre miss
france à nous notre concours à nous qui
fait partie du patrimoine qui fait
partie du patrimoine oui absolument et
pas du tout du matrimoine sécrète du
tout une mise en valeur des femmes
il aura fallu attendre 2010 pour qu'on
se rende compte que c'est une
humiliation totale cet hiver
merrick une double humiliation quand on
les fait défiler comme ça en maillot de
bain comme des animaux en effet dit pour
se fout de leur gueule on les attrape
maintenant très bien dans le ton du
concours de belote pas jugée la
meilleure femme de l'année parce qu'elle
a un beau coup un bon ben moi je trouve
que raphaël de ce qu'elle a dit je
trouve que j'allais dire frédéric alors
les fonds sous des bannières sa demande
arrêtons service sorte à ce que
justement on aura des teams wespiser
france qui sera avec jean luc jousse
camp dacquois très vite parce que vous
serez pas la séance finie je serai pas
là demain je suis je suis d'accord avec
raphaël aussi le sait ça près et parce
que à la limite qu'on puisse enlever ça
dans la mouvance du mouvement me touche
je comprends tout ça par contre il faut
enlever tout concourt voilà ce qu'on va
arrêter mais soit on arrête tout ares
avait misé sur l'apparence mollesse et
sinon on vire tous les concours à des
séminaires mais pour jean-pierre
pourquoi parce qu'il est c'est vrai il
avait